[Musique]
on va
oui
ce que
[Musique]
pas
m
allez
heureusement tous les samedis soirs de
plus en plus tard antenne 2 vous propose
lunettes noires pour nuits blanches
l'émission qui vous venge des autres
[Musique]
questions qu'on catherine lara quand je
pose d'école araldite j'ai la rade qui
se dilate bonne blague
meilleur espoir des amerloques au midem
crise c'est la première fois et parisse
john cleese badghis bande de nazes le
monty python qui fait un malheur avec
wanda exclu dans le jean michel shot et
tracy chapman ou un site owni child je
ne suis ni analphabètes ni [ __ ] comme une
bête
déclare françois valéry dans la série
c'est la fin des frais falher tatiana
rap a osé lever
antoine de caunes est il vraiment un
érudit rock 100% pures sont la
fantastique les briques de lunettes tout
sur avoriaz 89 drôlement calme et
monsieur 800000 ou encore captain
scented
scoop jean luc hennig écrit son premier
roman c'est sur les femmes enfin un
bordel pour femmes
après les frites et les moules les
belges se met au babel gum chibi franca
j'ai été un beatles pendant huit miller
déclare pitt baisse le batteur qui se
fait battre par une grosse tare exclut
les cures de l'an 2000 house of love
night club me suivait la bergère dans
les catacombes de paris la boîte la plus
privée du monde plus tout ce qui s'est
passé la semaine dernière plus tout ce
qui va se passer la semaine prochaine
night club et karina la danoise en
pleine rétrospectif godard alain parle
de jean-luc kwessi lunettes noires pour
nuits blanches l'émission qui zappe tout
seul citoyen
alors on et karina il ya un film avec
toi qui sort il s'appelle la sombre que
j'ai vu que je recommande aux gens
d'aller voir un effet ravi non c'est
rare que ça et là je le dis maintenant
c'est pas moi qui va nous rendre le tout
est là pour faire la promo on est bien
d'accord c'est toi qui vas nous
expliquer brièvement alors c'est un fait
de dénis péri c'est un film de l'europe
avec beaucoup de chansons en gros ça
raconte l'histoire d'une europe statut
leur enfance son petit frère qui arrive
qui débattront entièrement et qui peut
pas savoir que son confrère s'est
suicidé donc il commence à faire une
enquête et petit à petit il va
rencontrer tous les gens qui ont plus
récents frappé donc la veuve coup devant
moi qui chante le titre il y à kpn
d'azur avec qui il va voir une histoire
d'amour absolument passionnante
et puis au fur et à mesure il va
comprendre que son frère n'était pas du
tout la personne qu'ils croyaient qu'il
était et en même temps retrouvé le lui
même toit il sort le 18
et c'est un film de délibéré et je crois
que vraiment c'est un très très bon film
je rappe et eni a vraiment beaucoup de
talent c'est pas parce que sinon on va
te faire une petite interview à bandal
plus est ce que c'est l'interview ce qui
te plaît le plus dans la vie en général
c'est si la générosité je pense les gens
quand on les rencontre dans la rue qui
sont qui vous vous êtes à vivre ce qui
vous aident à vivre 10 ans paraissait
bien est ce qui te fait le plus chiant
un truc que tu supportes bon flamand
ben j'ai supporté ta peau il ya plein de
choses que je ne supportais pas le
racisme et les guerres la méchanceté
tout ce qui est ce qui est triste la
pauvreté du chômage
donc j'ai décidé de vous pas plus a
maintenant décidé l'année dernière c'est
cette gaffe et le plus grand score du
match je veux quand tu pleures ça marche
alors le film frida préféré faire le lit
pas la sonde parce que je suis là c'est
toujours le prochain titre mais c'est le
calme plat préféré
bon alors je dirais il dans le passé oui
ce que je peux pas y aller
non je dirais qu'il est fou et le plus
bon flanc le film vraiment sea king of
web raison tu dis oui tout à fait futile
le jour où j'ai rencontré ce metteur en
scène j'ai pu me casser une jambe ça
aurait été aussi bien ah non ça se
prévoit ni son anr d'entre nous l'a
assez le pire c'est peu
il ya la paix il y en a plusieurs
lancers
on avait tous des trucs pourris faudrait
qu'ils sous tendent et qu'est-ce que
j'ai vraiment fait un film qui me gonfle
est complètement bon mais là c'est très
méchant immédiat le je veux dire mais
des nues à ça c'est un film de jean luc
godard ainsi oui vraiment je n'aime pas
c'est vrai que tu as refusé de jouer
dans à bout de souffle à tout petit rôle
oui parce que j'ai rencontré il m'a dit
une mademoiselle il faut déshabillez moi
j'ai dit monsieur j'ai nommé déshabille
pas je suis reparti
trois mois plus tard j'ai reçu un
télégramme il m'a dit maître mot cette
fois ci c'est peut-être le rôle
principal alors maintenant on va passer
aux choses intimes va pas y couper
on a le droit de refi à bord dont il va
mettre de côté denis denis berry parce
que je veux dire bon hein ça sera un peu
calé qu'elle est là l'homme qui est à
préférer part d'une idée
alors si tu veux je te donne la liste
mais je compte sur toi pour être honnête
donc moi je vous ai déçu oui il ya des
gens qui se marient et ceux qui ne se
marient pas moi je me suis presque
toujours mariée avec des gens horrifiés
j'ai été mariée c'est vrai quelques fois
mais j'ai pas tellement connu des hommes
il n'y a pas tellement par exemple
n'était pas marié avec lui non ma chérie
évidemment j'ai eu quelques âmes ans
quand même nom mais ça quand on le voit
on comprend mais je veux dire que tu as
quand même eu une aventure avec jacques
perrin
c'était même si c'est vrai ça c'est pas
lui a menti avec moi aussi un abbé s'il
était là on ferait la même chose la
rassure toi là l'ont fait patte
artistique
alors jacques perrin maurice ronet
pierre fabre daniel duval je n'ai pas
dis moi ton préféré jean luc godard
on le sait dit moi mon mari mes nuits de
libérer tu veux pas en sortir la non
bon bah tu remplis qu'est ce que tu me
marie merveilleux et on est très
complices et tout va bien on va faire
plein de trucs pour en revenir à godard
qu'est-ce que tu préférais chez lui mais
il avait derrière ses lunettes noires
ces trucs puisque l'émission s'appelle
comme ça mais il avait un très beau
regard quand ils ne l'avaient pas ses
lunettes noires et d'être facilement
parce qu'ils avaient mais je crois que
c'était facile n'est complètement est
tirée comme quelque chose connexion on
n'explique pas quoi et puis bon ensuite
ça a été
histoire d'amour bouleversante tous les
cas pour moi vivant il y avait des hauts
et des bas bien sûr comme justement
l'armée dans l'est où les passions c'est
une très bonne enchaînement ce que tu
supportes et pas chez lui c'est bien un
truc que tu supportes pas chez lui ces
absences
j'étais tout le temps seul méta dit une
fois dans un interview tu as dit
peut-être mon intelligence n'a pas su se
mettre à mon niveau c'est des actions au
niveau c'est terrible virer truc pareil
j'étais quand même une enfant rejeté se
dirigeait pas été pourquoi l'école
annonce à sa crise d'ailleurs jean-luc
ce qui fait que quand même j'avais au
départ
pas beaucoup de cultures donc il m'a
tout appris jean-luc aussi jolie
réussite est à la fois sa femme ça
j'étais aussi comme une enfant parce que
bon c'est des professeurs oui c'est
peut-être maintenant ce que tu aimes le
plus sans toi à moi en toi à moi même
antoine mais je n'ai même pas tout il
est bien un truc que tu aimes bien je
pense que je suis plutôt et pas je sais
pas trop mauvaise ouais parce que t'es
marrant toi
suite
qu'est ce que tu as de plus sexy en toi
ton avis ce qui a fait craquer tous les
mac quoi c'est quoi
le savoir pour les filles le savent ce
genre de choses peut-être que c'est très
disponible et quand
est ce que tu as de moins sexy elle ne
dit pas ce sport n'aura pas content
parce qu'il a ses fans pour moi au monde
qui était vraiment sexy malinois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils n'ont pas peur de faire du haouz la
fccq ferait absolument 'crise en direct
de la nouvelle york
[Musique]
les stars
yu
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
non
bon
[Musique]
m
tiens
car
[Musique]
s
bach
[Musique]
j'ai
et
m
[Musique]
ce
m
[Musique]
c'était cruel avec un cas comme culture
s'était emporté on passe à l'art à des
questions qu'on encore plus conne que
dame
or catherine lara dernier au club sorte
une tournée qui s'appelle robe de
chambre c'est très astucieux en
s'ingéniant qui se rapproche des
musiques de chambre d'europe la chambre
des grosses alors tu te tapes toutes les
villes de moins de cent mille habitants
j'y vais à deux militaires des baux
petite amie bonbonnière çanakkale
sublime ou des maisons de la culture
juive y en a un paquet à fait car ce
contrat tu févr tu fais quoi là je vais
car en effet il
lors de l'ajout maxime le forestier sur
les plats sont pas très cher c'est ça
c'est surtout parce que le place à 150
da je crois qu'ils m'ont mise un peu
marre oui à deux ça fait 300 ballons n'a
pas envie d'aller au spectacle tout seul
alors on a fait les places à 4,85
roncquois étant des moutons histoire de
george sand blast est en train de se
faire appeler moi georges mas est en
train de se faire sérieusement j'ai
puisque j'ai l'accord du scénariste qui
sera une religion c'est pas mal c'est
pas mal pourquoi george sand passe parce
que j'avais ma femme pas du tout
aujourd'hui elle était complètement
plutôt le mot nymphomane est arrivé avec
cendres et
absolument à ce que sa vie me passionne
mais cette chanson non plus mais parce
que c'est une femme piloter c'est une
petite femme qui avait des choses à dire
et à faire et que en plus le casting qui
l'entouré plutôt intéressant ce choc
passé francis ému cessait de la croiser
en 1986 tu avoues elle après sa
télévision qui avaient fait de la
chirurgie esthétique c'est rare les les
stars qui avouent qu'ils auxquelles ont
recours à la chercheuse d un peu de
graisse sous les yeux je les fais
enlever c'est tout moi on s'envoie pas
on profite du progrès non mais on s'en
fout
jma quand tu seras plus âgés tu feras
des noms des listes et nous sommes ravis
que c'était la dernière fois
non j'étais plutôt c'était de famille
quoi mais le gérer des sables le nez n'a
jamais rien voulu comme ils ont savouré
comme il restera quand même temps je
suis bien né et je le reste tant attendu
n'a entendu parler des questions qu'on
bat les questions quand il y en a
partout
ouais sauf qu'ici au moins on l'avouera
exigences en cours
jean par exemple que tu partes sur un
vaisseau spatial oui dans la poule 4 ans
quand même c'est loin c'est l'eau
j'espère que tu vas bien entouré france
gall ou véronique sanson je prendrais
verrou écoute elle a dit toi
ah bon ouais sauf ailleurs tu vois donc
on est d'accord pour partir toutes les
deux oui mais sauf qu'elle a dit qu'elle
prendrait un petit
mallet pour se protéger un bail est
meilleur pour leur soirée voyage
elle a dit c'est pas grave mais moi
j'aurai mon petit je me suis dit oh moi
avec lequel je suis sûr de m'éclater ça
je connais bien françois mitterrand ttt
cote avec lui et moi c'est le cas de le
dire
françois mitterrand bon un jour il me
demande je dis comme ça j'aimerais bien
que vous ne trouviez une maîtresse alors
est-ce que tu préfèrerais tu vas qui tue
qui tue contacterait simone veil cette
femme arlette laguiller ou jean claude
brialy jeu télé le plus con le jeu télé
le plus con je vais en citer deux tu vas
me dire lequel est le plus bête c'est
presque fait gaffe sont très cons tous
les deux le juste prix assez bien sonnés
les magots
réfléchis bien ah oui c'est du juste
prix me semble très très fort encore
encore plus content que prévu mais c'est
bon tout le monde dit juste prix bon jeu
ça me fait réfléchir
imagine que tu puisses faire interdire
quelqu'un de télévision geminis de la
culture ouais tu peux faire interdire
quelqu'un télévision est-ce que tu
ferais interdite sébastien vous savez
tout fais gaffe c'est terrible ça des
artistes parce que nous avons tous les
deux dès 20h30 peut être que je te
fâcher avec l'un ou avec l'autre
ou alors d'esquiver la question
ce qui ne serait pas très honnête on
verra non mais j'ai pas envie de virer
un métier ils vireront tout seul sans
toi ça va c'est mme harel 25 est
d'accord alors maintenant on va passer
au conte sentiment contraire
un jour je sais pas tu vas encore plus
de disques d'habitude et puis tu dis
quand même là je vais beaucoup d'argent
je vais faire un grand bonheur est-ce
que cet argent tu préfèrerais le donner
à des petits noirs de soweto ou à des
petites palestiniens de gaza a cédé
question pencher plus con tu meurs là
gaza ne saurait pas choisir je verrai au
où les petits plats qui d'afrique du sud
où les petits palestiniens de palestine
penser à rien
en afrique du sud en afrique du sud
serait partial mais je m'en fous partout
je fasse un choix
je me rattraperai une autre fois alors
dernière question qu'on la pire de
toutes
je prête à huy 287 et 129
ça fait combien 287 et 129
ça fait beaucoup beaucoup de millions
pour vous conduire s'est inspiré aller
voter c'est ce que j'apprécie c'est je
retiens rien 289 et 127
416 exclut la dernier enfant du rock and
roll s'appelle tony chime jean-michel
choc des tracy chapman
on fait pas mieux
[Musique]
plusieurs scènes bébé s'appelle
ce cas
[Musique]
merci à toi
tous
oui
[Musique]
un test
non
[Musique]
m
certains
[Musique]
mémoire
m
[Musique]
le même chemin
mais
[Musique]
non
c'est
nous sommes
[Musique]
mais jusqu'à
quand
[Musique]
ça
non
[Musique]
à
c'était tony childs on ne zappe pas on
regarde le taux interview de john cleese
le monty python café vandales
[Musique]
pas du tout
moi je m'en fous
joe cole a fini en hausse
arrive de nous 5 devant un écran petit
chaperon rouge gueule mais sheila et
ringo starr
[Musique]
dans la série c'est la fin des frais
falher voici touch et l'arabe c'est du
haouz helvétique
j'y suis plus suisse qui toi moi si j'y
vais j'y dis merde
[Musique]
tout à fait
après 2
[Musique]
ah ah
on ne change pas de sujet on reste avec
françois valéry que personne il savait
qu'il était pas [ __ ] comme une bête qui
était pas un alphabet qu'il était né en
rond qui s'appelait jean louis mougeot
aller alors voilà françois valéry
bonsoir j'ai vu un film qui s'appelle
freddie 4 et en première partie disons
avant la pub tu es un clip de toi
absolument insensé c'est vrai ou qui
s'appelle esclaves de la musique où tu
fasses un peu un coup changement comme
ça à la jackson thriller où tu étais
dire l'otice blanchi a pas de raison
qu'on se marre 6 voilà quand tu te
noirci complètement cirque eta la fin tu
veux tellement avec noir que tu te mets
de la boue
ouais oui parce que bon c'est le site
une chanson qui fait un transfert
c'est quelqu'un qui font françois
complètement sur papier noir par rapport
à la musique gospel
j'ai fait ce truc parce que l'idée est
intéressante à ce niveau là autour de la
cour sur la gueule parce que c'était
quand il enterre ses tarifs voilà donc
c'est pas un peu une façon de faire
scandale comme ça qu'on voit françois
valéry quelques images
20h30 bush a encore dit la semaine
dernière que tu as déclare une fois oui
acheter mais disent je sais ça fait un
peu bête
c'est vrai ça fait qu'on encore mais sa
palette longtemps été un peu symboles
comme ça chanteur joe 10,1 le chanteur
pour midinettes lyonnais propres et
gentillet mais on sait pas grand chose
de toi
[Musique]
parvenir je t'appelle comment jean-louis
nos jours d'après françois parce que
c'était mitterrand et valéry giscard
d'estaing
je suis un peu un peu mystique moi et je
crois beaucoup en voyant t à ces trucs
là et c'est une voyante qui m'a donné ce
nom là sans bouger les tables ouais ça
marche évident je t'appelle comme
bonjour jean louis jean louis mougeot
ouais voilà bon ton surnom maintenant
pain surnom comment elle s'appelle la de
relativité françois à bon temps mais pas
mon gros poussin montout signer un bébé
alors anthropologie rapidement comme est
une mesure je suis pas un mètre pèse
combien la gym et gris jeu près 68 kg
gmail et cie qui les dents ça va ça va
bon alors les cheveux tu n'es pas blanc
si je suis blanc mais je fais des
petites neiges qui n'était pas besoin
déploré t sur 1 c'est la vraie couleur
de cheveux
les yeux sont marron c'est ça ici une
particulier opération
non c'est dommage non cicatrices
j'en ai une dans la tête je prends de
compter sur la tête un jour oui en quoi
en battant j'ai une cicatrice la whey un
coup de couteau la d'accord mais là dit
chronique allergies non tu feras des
implants quand tu seras plus âgé des
liftings trucs comme ça
pourquoi pas je sais pourquoi non
pourquoi page pourquoi pas tu me diras
pas où tu lui diras ce catherine lara le
dit peut-être eliane et en algérie ça je
savais pas tu es né ou en algérie à oran
c'est vrai que par l'espagnol tente est
détournée ma mère nous parle espagnol
par un tout petit peu espagnol parce que
tu sais en algérie avait beaucoup de
colonies espagnoles et par contre du
côté d'alger s'est écoulé nuttall
gaffeur alors un jour c'est assez faire
prêter le seul mais c'est dur un jour
cela dit il faut y aller pour partir
c'était en 72 62 moi j'y crois
moi j'ai connu si tu veux vraiment le
départ d'algérie
j'ai tellement que j'avais 8 ans ouais
mais j'ai connu si tu veux vraiment le
stéréotype de la du débardage juriste à
direct matin
r soeur d'arriver en france les valoches
et où j'ai vraiment connu ça et si tu
veux bon sur le coup je réalisais pas
j'ai réalisé plus tard bonne chose plus
tard j'ai pas eu de père parce qu'il
s'est classé quand j'avais l'âge de 4
ans c'est un truc qui m'a marqué après
qui m'a marqué après surtout quand j'y
vis j'y retourne même j'avais j'ai
chanté j'ai surtout avec ma mère je
chantais à alger de deux soirs ouais et
quand j'ai fait une chanson qui
s'appelle laurent 62 les musiciens va un
peu peur où il y avait 4000 arables
pendant deux soirs qui était froide
saeki qui s'appropriait un petit peu
françois valéry et quels sont tes
rapports aujourd'hui avec les arabes que
tu france - parce que finalement on
pourrait dire le fait que les arabes en
france justifierait théâtre y ait des
français en algérie
moi je m'entends vachement en examen
laissez moi je n'ai pas souvenance de
du racisme je suis connue on a connu la
loi si moi j'ai connu le racisme parce
que quand j'arrive je me souviens quand
je suis venu d'algérie à l'âge de 10 ans
je me souvenais on me disait beaucoup ça
le pied-noir tourner la compagnie ça
déconne il faut tu l'a connu ici en
arrivant ouais alors tu as dit aussi
j'ai une certaine culture j'ai rien de
neuf à bet on prend toujours pour un
alphabet c'est vrai nom tient il c'est
vrai qu'on a tendance à prendre les
chanteurs dit populaire pour des cons je
suis pas spécialement contre france par
la source de la loire par exemple tu
sais où c'est non mais c'est pas il sait
pour moi c'est un critère de quelque 1
615 tu connais quoi mais quand même
ouais ouais
la source de la loire tu sais je connais
les comprendre quel était le nom j'ai
envie d'aider les gens je suis jamais
été très fort tu fais de la musique de
film aussi ça les gens le savent moi et
il ya d'ailleurs avec anna johnson qui a
dit nous en amérique on à quincy jones
en france vous avez en france vous avez
unis reçoivent les risques énormes
à mon avis elle a déconné toit devait
être un peu amoureux est amoureuse de
toi
non mais là mon avis avec icon aimé
son plein on parle de musique de film
est génial unix contre toi et moi je
devais m'engager septentrion non ça va
être un triomphe je vais te dire
pourquoi
ouais parce que si tu vas y ça venir
savais tu connaissais pas très bien la
route de ceux de cette pop star moi je
voyais tout bien au début c'était un
mélange pour moi de tina turner de
streisand et lui savait pas trop tu t'es
drogués jamais jamais un jour on m'a
fait que les maps et artistes
ouais c'était bruce springsteen sur
scène mais je peux pas l'expliquer mais
s'est pas montré ouais d'arrêter là
c'est a fait tourner la tête cette
annonce est pas montré je préfère boire
deux trois verres de whisky sers toi
ouais alors l'amour maintenant un passif
moi à une fabre remarquable c'est vrai a
assez vous êtes rencontrés comment avec
nicole cup je te raconte pas un petit
peu comme ça il se sera pas du ici paris
un jour il y avait c'était un
anniversaire d'un copain moi qui ai un
restaurant
il s'appelle le bouvier puissamment
merdé qui allait alors j'ai dit à denis
mon attachée de presse et amie surtout
puissamment mer dim dit tu sais tu peux
pas faire ça c'est un mec sympa je dis
mais qui a marre india qui s'établit à
nicole calfan et la chine mais c'est
vrai de faire bouger alors j je viens
mais tu me la faut à ma table il ya un
coup de fouet et si tu es un coup de
foudre de sa part parce que moi je vous
dis qu'on cesse comme ça qu'est ce que
vous foutez km commandes baissent quand
je vois qu'on trouvera dans paris match
c'est un peu ce que c'est vrai elle
comédie-française être moins chanteur
il faut plus
et je lui dit une phrase jeudi
parce qu on s'emmerdait un peu jeudi en
serait tellement bien ce qu'elle t'a dit
pourquoi pas ouais c'est charmant décor
à ce point ici paris la sellette biotech
rose donc c'est donc c'est un peu elle
quitta je veux dire la têt dragueur toi
comme j'aime beaucoup les femmes n'ont
pas les jeunes filles et femmes femmes
étaient largués tulard les pépés où tu
te fait larguer ou comment ça se passe
là si je te dis que j'ai connus qu'en
principe ce jeu là qui va me prendre
pour un prétentieux mais c'est vrai mais
en principe ça se passe comme ça sous
ses pieds noirs peut-être un peu non
cotées seront aussi des jaloux la maison
mais tu sais moi j'ai une femme à part
moi j'ai une femme c'est ma soeur ma
femme était pudique aux mecs vous
balader à pour la maison peu
oui je me balade à paul parce qu'il ya
des gens devant le petit nom en face
dans le petit et si quand je prends mon
bain il vient me voir mais
je peux pas me balader à poil parce qu'à
la bonne pâte à l'honneur ce jeu je peux
pas mort dernière clairement rester là
avec le physique que tu as est ce que tu
as déjà eu des spas des tentations
homosexuels des expériences
homosexuelles je vais te dire un truc
voilà grâce à jouer je vais te dire un
truc j'ai un collaborateur qui
homosexuels complètement mais qui n'est
dit ti c mon pauvre en soit il a toutes
les qualités
ces textes d'ahmed qui nous a quand même
fort gay 800 1000 watts sous le nom de
captain sensible nous refait le coup
mais en plus doux avec toys take over
[Musique]
la rue
sauf le maillot jaune ici
ce cas
[Musique]
à
n'espérez pas de me refaire gittaz entre
les coeurs part de lightspeed
interdisent note sur la part des
actionnaires
[Musique]
après le capitaine sensible voici le
seul animateur télé qui s'exporte en
europe
j'ai dit antoine de caunes mesdames
messieurs je fais ma vie rock'n'roll
avec antoine de caunes et
[Musique]
seul animateur de télé françaises
exportent c'est à dire que la rapide aux
qui existaient l'année dernière soit eu
d
existe maintenant sur la bbc two way on
a fait une première série de six
épisodes qui a démarré sur bbc one en
avant et puis ça va redémarrer début
février sur l'ebit si tous et par la
même occasion en italie en allemagne
c'est le repos et il en est le rédacteur
en chef
donc c'est un match au sommet toi tu
bosses à l'europe numéro tu fais quoi
moi je suis animateur réalisateur
programmateur je vous ai tous les
week-ends et l'audience commence à
remonter ça va bien entendu et ali bey
et à lille et je j'assure la chronique
des tubes de tous les noms latins et des
papiers régulièrement ses pigistes et
comme on dit on va y aller légiste
régulier exactement régulier on va y
aller antoine tu es prêt je connais je
veux te graver dans ma vie par johnny
hallyday ouais ouais version originale
tu sais quoi attends attends attends
le titre de l'auteur
le titre et puis les auteurs pas
d'accord total
je sais pas non non je pense que c'est
un type d'otis redding mais tu n'as même
pas sûr c'est un titre des beatles got
to get you into my life bravo à une
autre cover que si elle préfère t parce
qu'il joue sa place
ouais ça fait un beau bigot il ya une
autre cover de cette chanson qui a été
fait
oui tu sais pas toujours je veux te
gravée dans mon coeur au nom de got to
get you into my life france et non en
anglais attend non moi j'ai maintenant
j'en connais une américaine
si j'étais les italiens j'en connais une
américaine american airlines garde non
si bon et si elle existe
je te crois sur parole la plus connue
c'est has been and fire oui c'est vrai
d'accord en tirer
[Applaudissements]
prochaine très bien mon cher ami il ya
des chances alors est-ce que tu as connu
il y a toujours un coin qui me rappelle
bien sûr et les mutuelles
ouais en français dé renvoyer son
feuilleton remind me samedi chaud bravo
et merci dans des niveaux élevés ce
moment c'est la mode
les accidents d'avion alors cochrane
celui des morts je dis tout de suite il
est à mort en alliant les hôpitaux ne
marchent pas à lui par contre 6 points à
grand rockeur kasri d'accord ok ça va
c'est le jeu voilà maintenant on va
passer les chansons c'est dommage parce
qu'ils sont les accidents d'avion
jusqu'à sa mort il ya leonard quénard
ouais c'est ça il faut les lire ce
procès c'est dommage on va passer aux
chansons qui ont un jour de la semaine
dans le titre je te dis par exemple une
chanson je te dis groupe sinon c'est
impossible
j'ai dit une chanson des stones ce avec
tous des maisons mobiles tuesdays bravo
[Applaudissements]
une chanson d easybeats avec ride et une
chanson je dois pas d'une avancée les
demandes des demandes des mondes
demandait ça y est oui après une chanson
de lennon avec sunbay c'est une bonne
question
merci de me la poser une chanson de
l'état bloody sunday note 6 10 sur wii
c'est exactement ça bravo mais c'est ça
c'est bien on va passer le jeune homme a
topé maintenant je te dis une onomatopée
pour toi j'ai une le nomma taupe et
étudie le nom du chanteur et tutti
frutti tutti frutti way version
française ou non en version originale il
te retiens bravo
à leur décharge de rendre on va voir
version originale c'est pas d'avis déjà
versé environ deux ados ont décrit ce
que tu vois on suivra les crystals bien
sûr oublier d'oubli et dante pense à
vous
là
elle n'a pas trouvé gnac et tillac si
bobby darin vous n'êtes pas l'origine il
a fait le reste
oui oui la version originale et coster
voit un veau j'te dis tout de suite
bigot l'intimidation qui consiste à dire
bobby darin et que ton pote qui dit
bobby gaye seller coster oui d'accord
mais la version originale c'est les
coasters c'est vrai d'accord bon alors à
toi maintenant illégal et à david gagné
georgie fame
je me suis parfois comme l'est le super
pactole c'est la distance
ah ouais c'est l'énorme super pactole
sur l'antenne de ça tu connais la maison
alors est-ce que tu connais les birds tu
connais les birth bien entendu avec un
avec un y manger tu nous parles des
burns avec un lit des peurs de la can i
où ce ne sont pas les yardbirds bien
évidemment et ce qu'il entend par là et
oui dur c'est super fait assez la
question ouais c'est la question chère
ça si la gouaille mais là non on ne
souffle pas vigo je vois des titres avec
bird bird bird
oh la la c'est sa brave
[Applaudissements]
face à ces petites bêtes
c'est un film gadget il est très dur
djaoui tous les faire marcher les
gadgets s'éteint c'est un groupe meute
anglais avec ronald pofalla on parle
surtout de spécialistes d'un spécialiste
non plus plus maintenant c'est fini ça
rentre était avant alors à toi
maintenant
l'origine du nom d olive badioli
[Applaudissements]
c'est plutôt la main dans la main je
sais pas leur temps et à combien la
justice il comptait il ya longtemps
alors entre amis on compte jamais cette
a4 nom est allé voir au dos
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on aura tout vu après les frites et les
moules les belges se met au bal gamme
tibi franca je vous ai apporté les
bonbons comme disait jacques kate est
loin d'en être une
[Musique]
oui
ag
[Musique]
je
le plus
tu es
[Musique]
les cheveux
qui
[Musique]
shi
harry
[Musique]
oui
sugar sugar c'était tb franck on se
retrouve au privilège pour fêter le
bicentenaire avec jean luc hennig encore
plus sugar bon alors jean-luc ai dit que
tu étais journaliste et écrivain ttv dax
chef de rolling stones qu'est ce qui
s'est passé comment ça se fait qu'il y
ait plus gros je me suis un petit peu
engueulé dix ans avec le patron d'alors
lionel road car tagro qui maintenant
d'ailleurs j'ai vu sur l'ours il est lui
rédacteur en chef ah oui oui il est tout
il est regardé comme ça des empereurs et
a commencé à libération en créant
sandwich ce qui n'est pas rien et puis
on aime avant même avant je ne sera pas
libération dans les années dans les
années qu'on m'avait promis à 74 et
après tu as créé sandwich ce qui est par
ailleurs et donc un jour qui est un
journal de petites annonces gratuites de
fait culturel assez hard d'ailleurs faut
bien le dire
et puis alors un jour tu es parti de
sandwichs comme tu comme tu viens de
partir de rolling stones et tu as fait
un truc très étonnant faim depuis c'est
devenu très à la mode le tout a été le
premier à le faire
tu as fait une grande annonce une petite
annonce géante dans la presse c'était
une bonne page non c'était une pleine
page oui j'ai payé 40 mille france
voulaient la passer dans le monde mais
le monde a refusé jacques fauvet a
prouvé sa très indécent et je nommais
les patrons pas être nommé
kit hommage à tous les patrons de presse
de l'époque et je disais vraiment vous
n'êtes pas joignable on essaie de les
avoir au téléphone et vous ne pouvez pas
vous ne pouvez même pas répondre eh bien
moi je vais peut-être davis avait fait
ça dans le frère des biches fait ça
j'avais été les deux premiers avec bette
davis
ah oui bette davis bien enfants ouais et
gbe le téléphone est en marche et wiz ça
marche un manque de pot les gens qui
t'ont répondu c'était fr3 spécificité
moati seven ou et guy thomas et qui
alors il ya eu un problème peut penser
qu'à les ventes des réfrigérateurs et on
va le dire je m'endette août les sexuel
allaient vote utilisé un mec est bien
montée peut passer une annonce dans
absolument dans cette émission et irm
pic avec rosie a eu la charmille avait
pas tous à l'époque c'est un scandale
énorme
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque était et été le
premier à vouloir faire une émission
sexe à la télé mais très courte et aux
états unis et d'europe est ensemble ça
existe aux états unis dans les
télévision par câble
mais en france ça n'existait pas il ya
eu quand même ça a provoqué un grave
problème au sein de la chaîne et surtout
le départ de baudis qui était qui la
télévision a perdu baudis à cause de toi
à cause est obligé d'aller travailler
chez son père mais je m'en excuse auprès
de bo d'un jeu c'est d'ailleurs sur
chariot l'accord dit n'est tout à fait
adorable à 12
ils étaient obligés d'aller travailler
chez son père et c'est comme ça qu'il
est devenu maire de tunis
c'est grâce à toi alors après avec le
cher guy hocquenghem j'ai fait une
émission sur sur oran qui s'appelait
comment on en a fait cinq cabré dire
pendant deux ans qui s'appelait
il s'appelait derrière la dune on y en
avait une qui s'appelait derrière la
dune oui qu'on est une émission un type
adorable de vacances de rencontre est
bien là d'une exactement que moi tout
est derrière la dune au milieu des je ne
sais pas moi au milieu des feuillages
c'est tout à fait ça enfin parallèlement
à tout ça tu as fait des listes a fait
les garçons basse
le voyeur la mort c'était quoi la mort
l'histoire c'était assez captivant j'ai
fait ça pendant six mois
là c'est là où tu disais qu'il ya des
gens qui achetaient des galas de faire
l'amour avec les cadavres et un chapitre
mais c'est vrai qu'à new york dans les
années folles
c'est à dire dans les années avancent il
dort
il y avait des finances à ce que ça se
passait effectivement new york à
manhattan dans une laverie
il y avait effectivement une un service
de garçon mort
vraiment c'est tout à fait étonnant
navarre je prends en a parlé dans un
livre qui s'appelle eddy blacks mais
c'est ahurissant je n'ai pas vu moi même
mais quelqu'un qui a le tragique et ça
ça a coûté assez cher ça coûtait 200
dollars
ah oui quand même
on avait le droit de passer une nuit
avec un mort c'était pas une nuit
c'était un quart d'heure un quart
d'heure c'est cher voilà tu sors ton
premier bouquin d'un roman dix ans et
mon huitième livre et c'est le premier
roman sait pas alors on va faire le coup
de la paix à gratuite quoi je veux dire
talons ben voila tu as trois minutes tu
vois on va la faire vraiment mieux mieux
qu'à 20h30 qui va nous expliquer
pourquoi il faut acheter ton bouquin bon
c'est donc une femme qui est une femme
de la grande bourgeoisie un peu exténué
un peu maladie qui coule un peu plus
d'argent et qui se dit vraiment je
m'ennuie à cap fréhel qu'après la côte
d'émeraude c'est sur la côte d'émeraude
c'est entre saint brieuc et dîna c'est
adorable mais c'est mortel est donc
cette femme se dit vraiment je ne sais
pas quoi faire de ma ville là et cette
ville là qu'est ce qu'on peut en faire
sinon à bordel pour dames avec les dames
vont là bas on leur promet des états
dans l'histoire de l'humanité
n'a existé de bordel pour d'art dans la
rome antique ça n'existait pas du tout
pas du tout et les ragots oui absolument
non ça n'a jamais existé jusqu'à ce que
la fille arrive alors la fille arrive la
fille arrive évidemment cette jeune
fille est très pimpante très betty boop
elle dit mais qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire moi l'amour ça s'est fait
comme ça ça se fait dans les champs
c'est exactement comme bernadette lafont
dans la fiancée du pirate bay moi j'ai
pas besoin de payer pour faire l'amour
moi je le fais comme ça et alors la
femme et elle va mettre en péril cette
demeure qui est fondée avant tout sur
l'argent assure le contrat et évidemment
ça se termine très mal je venais le
portrait chinois
absolument bon on va faire tu penses
bien qu'on va pas faire un portrait
chinois
je ne sais pas mais on va faire un anti
portrait chinois
[Musique]
si tu étais un vice
ben là à me dire oui oui c'était le pire
vis tu serais comme la plus lâche c'est
les gens quand on l'a quand on leur fait
le portrait chinois on leur dit c'était
une fleur du thriller qui dès l'annoncé
tt1 vie ce serait là tu serais l'âge
c'était une guerre tu serait laquelle
oh mais la dernière parce qu'elle était
la plus terrible où alors
iran irak parce que c'était vraiment
terrible mais la dernière guerre a été
pas mal la dernière elle était pas mal
bien réussi c'était collaborateurs tu
sais qu'ils n'avaient pas un cran mais
non mais c'est un jeu si tu étais un
grand collaborateur tu serais plus
maurice saxe je suis pas mal c'était un
supplice
oa supplice comment appelle-t-on ce
supplice où on écarte ça s'appelle de
laisser pas l'écarter parce que les
cartes et d'autres shows égaler un jour
car l'écartèlement l'écartèlement gsm
écartèlement peut-être ça c'est une
psychanalyse sept nations les sites
était un accident le pire des choses
c'est accident d'avion parce que je
prends souvent l'avion et comment ses
traits à la base est très à la mode en
angleterre je trouve que c'est meilleur
mais il faut pas prendre l'avion
rocktambule catherine lara s'en sort pas
mal
mais comment se sortir at-elle du blind
test réponse après sa chanson
[Musique]
g
qui
[Musique]
à
mais
[Musique]
toi tu n'aimes au guichet fermé
c'est toi
[Musique]
quoi
aussi
[Musique]
à
oh
on verra
la tête
[Musique]
toi tu sois dans moi je rêve l'histoire
nous dit ce père
plus tard
[Musique]
ça
à
ah ah
[Musique]
moi
ça
[Musique]
c'est
et
[Musique]
pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu vas voir tu as choisi que défilent
bon déjà ça va donner une indication ça
quand même
oui tu es prêt corte bonne idée
j'aimerais venir
elle vient de loin
[Musique]
c'est la belle italienne sait qui et
comment elle s'appelle appel namine
indiana et le clip du morceau c'est pas
permis point sur la police
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il faut pas longtemps la c4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un mec ça non c'est une heure
c'est toi je quitte pas jackie chan toi
certaines des chansons qui portent aussi
que l'abonné gagné s'appelait bien que
mal comment la touche et le clame me dis
plus haut point le ministre cette fois
je vais pas te le dire mais je te
regarde souffrir conquis le monde
je me régale il s'appelait sait cela
mais c'est une blonde c'est pas un
mannequin nom barbare écoute moi mais je
connais cette chanson par coeur mais là
à côté un certain mois s'appelle
[Musique]
en russie un bonus non jean-noël sa
force elle a chanté un truc comme ça
seigneurial makeba la version originale
c'est sûr mais ça en français
[Musique]
viser plus haut point le miz prend pas
la tête à ça je vais pas te le dire mais
je te regarde souffert comme tout le
monde je me régale c'est pas beau ça
s'appelle un mannequin en garde à
l'écouté mais là mais je connais cette
chanson par coeur mais là et qu était
encore temps
il s'appelle
[Musique]
en russie un bonus non direct ça font
pas ça pour ça qu'elle a chanté un truc
comme ça c'est la dame makeba la version
originale c'est sûr mais ça en français
cette ville ne souffle pas nonchalante
on n'est pas non non non mais j'ai pas
même si je ressens tap tap
ah oui bah écoute à ambon pas d'accord
mais moi je croyais qu'on était que tu
parlais d'un passé là ont cédé ce petit
rôle alors oui
[Applaudissements]
jamais vu ça c'est la première
bon voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
exclu lulu à genève l'homme les cures de
l'an 2000 sont des fanatiques de deux
points ouvrez les guillemets à maïs line
lustucru antoine house of love
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici
[Musique]
je sais
un bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
exclu lui c'était à bloc et maintenant
toujours exclu voici pete best une
histoire épouvantable et pest des
beatles aaron de news et de films qui ne
bouclent fame albert coleman which is a
very consommation fait mousser le web
because you were de fausses rumeurs de
beethoven shakhtar
non the mist one of the most of the
century terrasse your story 2 john paul
otellini au bouc
[Musique]
invité du colloque d'histoire ou dj
stoppeur de ces deux pays pour le
transit sur twitter
du personnel et 7,6 galzi gaspard xbox
world by starck et aka ringo starr ou
spleen
[Musique]
et le secret bancaire
cela va mieux
malek m
so what am
comme en suisse ait
[Musique]
non
audio fight macho steyn
night club in paris est une fête bergère
et son prophète et suivez votre bergère
dans les catacombes de paris entre 18 et
25 mètres des gens entre 18 et 25 ans
les cataphiles sont pourchassés par une
brigade spéciale des flics là dans ces
anciennes carrières que l'on a construit
pour faire des cathédrales les
cataphiles fend d'une aide club et y
aller sans guide
c'est du suicide il parlait de la
surface une fois cogner c'est pareil au
fait
l'entrée secrète se trouve sous un pont
de chemin de fer du 14e les catacombes
c'est un labyrinthe en trois dimensions
dessiné par m6 et cher m6 pas stéphane
bande de nazes 1989 bobino change de
look
fini le théâtre un peu ringard pour
coiffeur balèze mais pallez du 93 nous
avons pu y voir carême fine et qui après
s'être déshabillée enduite de sperme
s'est masturbé on se demande comment une
chaîne nationale peut diffuser ce genre
d'image on seule demande alors pendant
que maman fait ces cochonneries on va en
profiter pour vous annoncer quelques
concerts au palace west end le 18
janvier à 23h france gall indoor si que
vous avez été les premiers à voir dans
l'une est le 19 à 21h au même endroit et
attention 38 jeunes 20 + 26 à 20h 30 au
palace il ya un canard qu'il faut
absolument vous achetiez ces voyous à
cause d'un article super qui s'appelle
comment pis c'est quand on a la gaule
romane polanski claude challe galette
des rois aux bains les bains sont
tellement populaires qu'ils peuvent se
permettre de ne plus être vraiment
démocratique
[Musique]
chantal thomass sylvie grandes banques
c'est complexe mais qu'est ce qu'elle
paie m'arrive à la voile à marie c'est
ça c'est la cèze nec sont faits
je me suis fait une galette le jour des
rois je te raconte pas ce soir eva
ghadames au gibus tous les jeudis soirs
ce qu'on entend c'est l' ordonnance de
l'albatros assez du hard ambiance
valstar jamais trop tard
[Musique]
faites y un autre canard que vous
pourriez acheter ça s'appelle perfect
est un endroit où pour y aller ça
s'appelle le palace
c'est un lundi sur deux soirées l'aube
sexy
[Musique]
ce qu'on entend c'est le sprint et ça
s'appelle irish open c'est ce que je
vous souhaite à tous bande de nazes
c'était lunettes noires pour nuits
blanches l'émission qui prend le maquis
et n'oubliez pas contre les yeux rouges
les lunettes noires y'a qu'ça d'vrai
ah oui
m
ap
[Musique]
m
pas
le
poudre
à d
[Musique]
m
on va
il
[Musique]
je
nous
[Musique]
baa
et toi
m
ok
moi
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu